maybe some type of skin or something
an animal skin so audio is going
all right we're all good okay
and this can be the first one here from
the central east out here in nashville
from that central east location good to
be here
um on the back end today i got a local
sidekick this fellow riley
riley mao and you're of age right i am
okay beautiful man
all right let's get into the episode
[Music]
i'm having a diet coke i'm just sitting
on your front porch
wondering how could i be so far from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]
it come on here we go let's go baby it's
light
it's gonna take a little
time for me to set
that parking brake and let myself
there you go
[Music]
and that's it right there the shine
right there
and you know it because it's the same
one every time
you know it's almost like a ghost you
know it's uh
you it's it's there
you know what a lot of people don't want
to admit about ghosts
you know these days people too busy for
ghosts
you see it a lot you see they're on the
go everyone you know
people laying there at night and they're
just you know they're just
you know they're busy they're on their
phones they're looking at a app or
something
looking at a damn whatever fox hunter or
whatever that
robin hood the app that's really got all
these
you know millennials out here taking
their own lives and investing in damn
amazon or whatever
tesla's you know uh sound crack or
whatever the damn
whatever that stock is they're on but um
yeah
people busy too busy for ghosts
and you can feel that if you really
think about it you can feel the ghosts
starting to back up in the ether you can
feel them man
and that's when i get nervous because
when i was young you'd see a ghost you'd
hear it go what is that
that's a damn ghost over there you know
it was easy
something you know it happened outside
it happened inside what is it it's a
ghost
but now people are too busy for ghosts
and what is the repercussions of that
is what i'm wondering when the dark side
when the
you know when the ghost you know the
ghost
vestibule or whatever wherever ghosts
are
whenever that dam just gets too backed
up because nobody's seeing them
because i'd be pit man if i'm a ghost
and you used to get all you had all this
clout
and now you're at a you know there's a
children's sleepover and they don't give
a damn
they don't give a damn they're doing the
you know
virtual hula hooping or whatever or
tick-tocking or doing
you know blm the board game you know
they just did
it's just different times but anyway man
shout out ghost i don't even know what
i'm talking about
i'm over here today in um i am
in nashville
out of the central east this is the
central east
studio it's coming along i'll say that
this thing is coming along man uh
it um and you can see it on the youtube
it's uh you know i got here about five
days ago
got a painter in found an old man to
paint
and he had a little sidekick with him
and that fella was using drugs i think
but uh not on premises and i respect
that
and nah uh and i guess the right amount
of drugs that's what you want you want
painters you want contractors to be
using
appropriate amounts of drugs
um because you get a guy who's got you
know he's too sped up and next thing you
know he's painted you know
he's got your bathroom he's got a flat
enamel in your bathroom but he's also
[ __ ] you know
he's added a demi-gloss or something to
your damn
uh you know to your toyota tundra
and he's got half of that sp you know
he's spackled all the doors shut
because he's gassed up on too much dust
but you get a man who's just
even steven on the right amount of drugs
and he'll damn paint a one bedroom
and that's what we had here so getting
in into nashville i'm sitting here if
you're on the youtube
i got a silent assassin here with me
today or semi-silent
and this is a young fella named riley
mao
and um what is riley short for bud
riley okay man okay
so nothing see back in the old days
you'd have a longer name you know
rilandro you would be you know rolandro
or
you know lowrily or something longer and
riley would be short for something
right nope i'm just riley okay all right
beautiful man and you uh
and you are you're
i don't want to say you are from
originally
california correct but by way of japan
and hawaii
i guess so yeah okay i guess yeah my
grand my grandparents correct beautiful
man
yeah then beautiful jay has baby i love
hawaii
what island uh i like maui i like oahu
i don't like that i you know i haven't
been to the big one i haven't been to
um what is it the big one
the big island yeah it's just called the
big island oh damn yeah so yeah it
doesn't have a name dude i'm not going
you know what i'm saying i'm the kind of
guy you name it i'll show up
oh yeah but if it's nameless man i'm not
you know right i'm not
milling around at that but we've we got
riley here off the internet
and uh and just happy to have some
assistance here in nashville man thank
you
great to be here yeah thank you very
much brother um
what's been going on let me think about
this man um
so yeah i got here to nashville i want
to let people know what's going on
a lot of rumor mills oh theo knocked a
woman up
you know theo's got it you know he's
adopting they're doing foster children
out there
rumors that's rumors
you know rumors are just damn
you know it's not like it's not real
information it's just [ __ ] that
somebody made up
when they were high or something like
that but the real the truth is that i'm
here
and that we're just trying it out we got
the central e studio sprouting
okay we're bringing in do we're doing
unique stuff we got people of color okay
we got riley mao in here we got
guests that are gonna come on that are
unique we're trying to
you know change the vibe a little and
expound
people say well nashville what about
well because it's very
i'll tell you where nashville is three
hours from
cincinnati four hours from
columbus two hours from huntsville
alabama
which is kind of almost unfortunate but
um
27 hours from cape town
if you stop in amsterdam and qatar
so it's definitely it's uh you know
we're trying something out that's it
we're trying something out there's no
other information there's no
wedding bells there's nothing like that
and if i felt welcome here that's what
i've been asking myself really
a couple new things one um
i tried the mma
so i tried it man and it's basically uh
it's like full contact dmt man this
stuff mma is a real thing
and a lot of you guys know i've been uh
you know i've been trying it out and
having different experiences and
you know just being a fan um
you know i've been fortunate enough to
meet a lot of mma guys and
and do that kind of deal and uh and so
now i'm like just trying to check it out
i went in there
and i got that first well they made me
fight the women which is fine
you know and i don't like to call them
women but they seem like women i'll say
that
beautiful ladies and
and they whoop me man and they were
straw weight one of them was straw
weight
and uh
and i guess i'm straw weight and i'm
scarecrow straw i think that's the kind
of straw that's in me
um but i got in there it was over at
nashville mma
i hit up mike chandler and he got me
squared up
squared away over there and uh and it
was fun man it was
you know you get in there and you get in
the outfit
um you get into the ghee and you're just
you know it's very i mean you feel like
you could beat anybody in antifa or any
of these proud boys you could whip any
of their butts you get in there you just
kind of your arms are your weapons your
legs your feet
and uh yeah i mean i had to fight the
women you know it was definitely
it was there was definitely that moment
um
where it was like okay i'm excited i'm
keyed up i'm in here
and then they're like okay you you know
barbara's gonna
you know barbara's going to put you in a
leg lock or somebody
you know when i was young if you wanted
to know a woman you had to go
you know you had to look in her window
you had to lurk you to be
now there's more stalkers everybody's a
stalker if you go meet somebody in
person you drive past their house or you
park in their you know in their driveway
and have a smoothie or whatever
you're a criminal when i was young that
was
flirting kind of you'd drive over there
and sit outside say hey you know
yeah they were startled but it was it
was a little more that primal kind of
like um
have you ever seen that animal on the
nature channel that makes its feathers
real big so the other birds will come by
it was like that it was like that
so um what else happened to me
uh oh well i've already run into some
issues here locally i will say this at
the parks here
i took a little bit of bread out there
you know i took some biscuit out there
to the lake
to feed to some ducks and you know me
man if i'm in a new area i like to get
acclimated with the animals bro
i'll pet an animal you know i'll pick a
snail up and walk three or four feet
and set him down you know save him
[ __ ] five days of travel
that's who i am you know i'll pet a dog
i'll whistle at a falcon i'll [ __ ]
you know i go out and feed a duck i see
a duck i feed a duck and i give a duck
bread right
but i give him biscuit i had breakfast
they had a half a biscuit left you know
i'm watching my figure since i'm doing
mma now
i'm straw weight i'm currently female
straw weight
and uh
and so next thing you know i'm feeding
biscuit man and these ducks are fired up
uh these ducks are really keyed up you
could see ducks in the distance looking
you could see ducks that haven't even
been born yet you could see a duck peek
out of the egg
you know just hearing that there's a
kind of a new boss man in town
you know a new [ __ ] yeast santa you
know i'm out there delivering goods
so i'm feeding i've got you know i got
half of a nice biscuit and this is an
expensive biscuit it's probably a two
and a half dollar biscuit
so we're looking at a dollar 25 worth of
biscuit bread i'm out there feeding
these bastards over there perennial lake
or whatever it's called perennium lake
by the jester uh by the vestibule or
something
so anyway i'm feeding them next thing
you know i started getting i put
on my instagram story i start getting
dms people angry you can't give them
bread
you can't give them bread you know
they'll die
you know they'll oh this is what they
they said oh
if you give them bread they get too
jacked up on energy
and they will rape each other
look man i'm not doing all of that
i took a half a biscuit and went out
there to treat these animals
to get acclimated to the area
if somebody else if they're doing all it
you know i'm not doing part of
sexual abuse for animals i'm not doing
any of this
if they don't want bread they just
shouldn't come eat it that's not on me
people attacking me you're going to hell
bread boy
and then sending me two uh caskets and a
picture of a duck
emojis man
that's mother nature man if there's a
glitch in her pattern then
she will work it out and these ducks
look like they wanted the bread that's
the thing
you know it's like oh they can't digest
it they will rape each other
well look man i'm not i didn't come to
town to be part of that
you know i'm not doing those sex
trafficking i'm not doing that kind of
stuff i'm not doing you know
i came here i just you know i'm trying
to get acclimated to the area
you know when i was a child ducks would
eat bread have you ever given bread to a
duck riley
i have and did you i mean what are you
or
you know it's it's a lot of the
youngsters getting at me a lot of
millennials coming at me
you know do you know any of this
information i don't
um when i was back in california where
i'm originally from
um i live around what's called east lake
village
and there's always a whole bunch of
ducks in the lake all the time
um i would always as a kid go out there
and feed the ducks
that's what i would do in my childhood
um it was just a big
thing that everyone in the community did
it's a piece of culture i feel like
right i feel like it's a
piece of youth culture it is and do you
and i feel like that that
stretches over all cultures too i feel
like if you are black
white uh malaysian whatever
right feeding a bread to a duck is
normal
right i've seen literally anybody i
could imagine
doing it right exactly amen
so anyway right out of the gate they're
jumping on me
they're you know you're bad what are you
doing
take your bread back to california and
then they would call me the f word [ __ ]
you know just like like come on man
you know it's just it's like you can't
do anything
these days without somebody jumping down
your throat
and opening up a damn kitchenette you
know full of mostly knives
it's just that kind of place man uh that
kind of vibe
not the place here in nashville i'm just
saying that kind of vibe in the world
sometimes
um what else happened
uh oh i got to announce this i
am going to be doing some live shows
you know i'm a performer uh
riley mao i do performing i do stand up
i do
i'm an artist i guess you would say not
i wouldn't say artist
but you know i do comedy and so i'm
going to be doing live shows so i'm just
letting them know that
thank you i'm going to be performing in
dubuque and des moines that's going to
be september 25th and 26th i believe
and those uh that's all going to go on
sale on
wednesday of this week or tuesday
probably wednesday i think and uh you
can see it on the ig
uh you can see it online on socials um
and those are gonna be outdoor shows
there's gonna be different outdoor shows
and uh
and we're gonna just see how that goes
i'm experimenting i'm going to
experience it
i'm just going to lean into it
what else i hope everybody had a
wonderful labor day
you know i hope um
you know it's a weird year for labor day
because a lot of people haven't had work
but a lot of people are getting back to
work that's one thing i'm noticing
people are getting back to work
you know a few weeks ago i felt like
with the virus it was like people were
pretending like
we all started to kind of pretend and
now i feel like people are just like you
know what i'm
i'm gonna work and for the most part
people seem to be doing okay
um except for
this freaking lady this fl
who works out at big lots i'll say this
now we support a lot of small businesses
big businesses
you know from time to time we'll even
sell you some [ __ ] on here
against our own knowledge you know i've
read ads for something and the next
thing you know i get it and i'm like
damn
you know like a hammock with a hot tub
in it just
you know sometimes people are just
selling a real piece of [ __ ]
excuse my language man excuse my
language also raleigh
not a problem okay do you where you're
from do you guys use a lot of profanity
or what is it like over there
so i am a christian um and
an eagle scout um i don't do swearing at
all
okay um that's just not me but i mean
hey i don't i don't judge
okay well you can judge me i'm gonna let
you know that
awesome you can judge me up until the
point that i'm willing to accept it
and then i'm gonna try to use less of it
around you then
all right i might write some of the
words down and show you some of the ones
in advance that i'm going to use from
now on just
i just don't want there to be not fair
communication sure
okay cool man thank you well i will tell
you this though
if you want to go to big lots it is a
real
h-e-l-l of a store
okay if you want to go to big lots
mercantile
you roll in there they don't even know
what they're selling anymore
you know they had a 180 ounce coffee pot
in the front
what and and uh it came with uh
the the maker the coffee maker looked
like a damn washing machine
you know just like who how we got you
would need half a family to even tip the
thing over and pour a cup
or a bucket you know i guess it's for
you know that
kind of that group think mentality or
whatever but
but anyway i'm in there i'm looking for
stuff
you know oh excuse me a little bit of
my chest is acting up i have i'm having
a diet coke
it's just a mini it's 7.5 ounces but
um so anyway i'm at the big lots and i'm
trying to get a few things and i don't
want to be there
i wish i'd have walked into a target
but i'd been driving and i was wearing
shoes with no socks
and my feet were real sweaty and i was
angry
i started to get angry i hadn't eaten
breakfast
and it was about 1 30.
and and i just couldn't handle myself
anymore
and i was just angry and the car i got a
rental car it keeps
gearing into s and i don't know what
that is
you know i've seen the regulars in you
know n d
p r and this one every time you try to
go to d it ends up in s and i just don't
know what's going on and just
i was just furious man so i parked in a
dang you know when i get angry where i'm
from if men get upset
they would drive over to a wind dixie
which was a chain grocer and they would
park in the lot
sometimes you see them crying over there
or
you know looking at pornography
pleasuring themselves all kind of stuff
but it was kind of like a
it was just like a place where men would
escape they'd park their truck behind
the winn-dixie in the parking lot
and then they would just you know almost
release
whatever they had to do whether it was
sexual or emotional
you'd see somebody crying so hard they'd
open the truck of their door
to let the tears all out you know like
they were vomiting
and um and
now uh so anyway so that flares up in me
sometimes so that's what happened
you know i pulled over there i haven't
eaten
and i've been i was trying to eat
healthy that was my goal for the day and
all i can think about is a damn wendy's
you know junior whatever it is whatever
killed dave thomas his favorite one that
one
the good one so i'm thinking about that
and i don't have socks on in my shoes
and i don't care in the beginning of the
day if i wear socks without shoes i
think it's kind of stylish
but halfway through the day your feet
get sweaty
and then i can feel myself ruining my
shoes
and these were nice shoes they were a
gift from someone
so i'm just losing it and i'll just say
look man i just i got to get a few
things
i'm going to go into a place called big
lots
so i go in i got me a few items i get to
the register
um oh no first when i went in the lady
immediately pulls me over to sign up for
a five dollar gift card right
now i'm going to be do i look successful
to you or not riley at all and you can
be totally honest
you look very successful really
just the way that you present your
presentation wow present your
presentation the way you
just act on camera the way that you show
what you do okay okay good
thank you thank you thank you good here
the millennial perspective
uh and what i'm saying is this man that
i i'm happy to be a part of everything i
want to be a part of society i want to
be
a regular man i do not need to spend
12 minutes getting a 5 off coupon
okay this lady couldn't figure out the
machine and i wanted to leave i wanted
to go i wanted to get the few things i
was already angry
i wanted that mc you know that bacon
doubler or whatever i just
i had sweat in my shoes i was sad
i was just disappointed i just wanted to
be behind the damn wind dixie
and i'd been i honestly masturbated a
couple nights in a row i don't like to
this is something i probably shouldn't
tell you since we don't even know each
other and who knows if we're even going
to work together
uh riley mao but i do not prefer to
masturbate
it doesn't make me feel good so i do it
sometimes
as a i don't want to do it
so just letting you know that so you
know what i'm referencing when i say
that but
anyway so i didn't want to do it and
anyway so next you know i'm at big lots
i get the dang thing it's
five minutes but the whole time she's
having me fill out this form and stuff
and get the gift card
and i don't want to be at big lots i
don't want to be at big lots dude i
parked there
because i was not feeling good and i
went inside
at a certain point you you just
you know i figured you know they have
maybe a protein bar i need to see about
getting a desk for the studio you know
maybe it'll have some things
but i get in the first thing you see
they got a hundred and eight you know 85
ounce damn coffee pot
and there's a kid shooting a basketball
into them i was like what in this
store makes no sense you know they got
the world's largest pillow or something
it's like eight feet by eight feet
where are you gonna use it there's no
place for that
so anyway there's just a lot of stuff in
there that you don't need
and that's why they're going out of
business well anyway the lady
the lady keeps asking me if i'm wearing
cologne i'm not wearing any cologne
right and she won't take no for an
answer
not being real real cool anyway
i walk around there and
uh and it's just nothing makes any sense
they all have like a um
a thing of cheetos like a literally like
a burlap bag full of
cheetos and then right next to it
they'll have like an aquarium
and then they'll have uh one of those
fountains like a fake stone
fountain where the little guy is
urinating into the bird bath you know
what i'm talking about riley
you ever seen those or not i've seen
them everywhere
you have i have okay and when you see
that what do you feel like what is that
what is that is that cool is that lame
what is it
i mean i i just don't really
i don't really have an opinion i just i
see it and i just
disregarded i i mean i couldn't care
less
honestly okay and there you go that's
the young perspective
they don't care and it's fine
i'm not judging you or anything i'm just
when i was young when they when they
came out with the bird bath
baby that would urinate the little
sheriff or whatever the little
angel boy and he's urinating into the
birdbath
oh dude it was like
that was our 4k
you know that was
that was our
vietnam that was it was so exciting no
one had ever seen it
a bird bath had just been a place where
birds would come to bathe and kind of go
on about their business
and now suddenly it was this you know
there was a stone
baby and he's urinating it was just more
exciting
so anyway um but anyway this is all
besides the point
so i here's what happened is i get some
stuff that i do not want
and i'm buying out of sheer anger i'm
wandering around the store
i'm just i'm not well every other aisle
has sandals in it it's just like what is
going on here
what is going on here it's basically
like a trap house
for it's almost like a halfway house for
[ __ ] that should be
at target it's like oh here's a lawn
chair that got
that was doing heroin you know here's a
uh oh here's a swing set that they
caught with a couple grams of coat
you know it's just everything there kind
of
it's like it's all part of a big foster
family or something and nobody's paying
the rent that's what big lots is if you
haven't been to big lots
so anyway i'm leaving i'm at the end of
my rope
and at the end of my journey in there
and i did i will be honest i ate two
protein bars in there that i
i paid for one of them i'll be honest
with you
i don't want to lie to you riley i paid
for one of them
you know and in your culture do people
lie a lot is there a lot of dishonor in
lying
um yeah yeah there's a lot of lying
i mean a lot of it could be i mean
there's plenty of examples um
lying could until um
what was i going to say keeping
surprises uh
i'm not saying that's one of them
another one could be
i mean just just flat out lying because
they don't want to maybe hurt someone
um it honestly depends but yeah lying is
a big thing it it just honestly depends
on
what the lying is about okay and in your
grandparents culture they
do they do you notice anything different
between your grandparents culture and
your parents culture as of
opposed to lying i'm just trying to get
to the root i know
your family has deeper roots in the
universe probably than mine
so i'm just trying to establish uh
do they care more about lying do you
feel like
yes okay yeah i feel so i feel that
there you go thank you
so what i'm saying is this i'm at big
lots i'm leaving and the lady
i get up to the register and i'll say
this the lady was not nice
i tried to be cool i said hello how are
you doing
no response zero response
and i'm already not doing well okay
i'm already not doing well
okay i have 200 feet
of telephone cable
in my buggy i have [ __ ] i do not need in
there
okay i got a 60 pack of baby ruth
minis i don't want any of this
i want to get out of the store and i
already feel compromised i've got the
five dollar coupon i've already spent
the time getting it
i feel like i at least need to use it
i did get two throw pillows that aren't
that bad
anyway the lady not being nice
very rubenesque woman okay
and and i'm not striking low here i'm
just saying
she wasn't cool and her name tag
said largeish on it
now if you're going to have a child we
all probably have
you know i don't have children you have
children
okay well you're gonna have them
probably
or you could probably still be adopted
if you wanted to be but what i'm telling
you man is that if you have a
child and you don't name it something
that
i get you don't have a child that could
be big
and name it largeish okay and the lady's
giving me
a a hard time and i don't know if it was
if it was indian or native american um
but largesh was not happy she put all of
my stuff i bought into
one bag okay
okay riley yes
yes like i'm santa claus or something
right like everything into
one sack and she can tell if she would
have looked in my eyes
she would know i'm not doing i wasn't
doing very well
um so anyway man it just was a rough
welcome it was a rough welcome here
know it was a really really rough
welcome between
um between largesh being a real peace
just not just not cool
you know
and and i even when i left i i i didn't
look at her name tag
immediately and then i was like oh well
i just tried to be nice you try to
one-up them at the end and still be nice
you know
and i said oh thank you very much and
then i looked at the tag
and i could barely get the largesh
it just because it almost seemed like i
was making fun of her because she was a
larger woman you know
like if you have a daughter and you're
say if you're if you are rubenesque
you're talk
you know uh
i'm just saying if you and your wife or
spouse have
some physical attributes if both y'all
are bigger people
you're not gonna name your son fat
randall
you know you just it just it's not gonna
behoove him
you know you're not gonna name your boy
a little uh
big rounder you know
or marble daddy or gravity junkie you
know you're not going to name your kid
things
so anyway but largeish was a real [ __ ]
and i'm sorry to say that i know you're
in here
and uh and i shouldn't have said it
again
i know you do though and i don't want to
i just don't want things to get
out of control so anyway
um but yeah i'm here in nashville man
i'm excited i
did uh oh i'll tell you what happened
today's episode is brought to you by
hawthorne now a lot of people smell bad
people have been smelling bad for
centuries decades even
and a lot of times you'll see somebody
and they stink and their daddy stinks
like damn man and you'll leave and
sometimes you'll even drive across town
to go to their aunt's house or their
grandmother's house
you'd be like oh there's no way that
they all gonna stink
and they all stink man and that's
unsurprising but it's also surprising
and that's called
stinking but what i'm telling you is you
can change all of that
i mean you want to smell so good that it
gets into your dna
and the company the group the outfit
that can help you
is called hawthorne
you know i went to their website and
they have a website online and you could
even do it on your phone
and they ask you a couple of things
about yourself well are you active or
you inactive
you know are you skydiving or you're
wheelchairing
you know they ask you what kind of but
you know do you like to wear tank tops
or do you like to wear a suit do you
like to
be outside with your children do you
like to be alone do you like to
skateboard
do you like to play gin rummy they ask
you different things
questions quizzicals and you answer them
and then at the end of the
end of the quiz they hit you with two
cents
two fragrances bruh and they say hey
this is how you smell this is how you
could smell
and they give you one for being active
and one for being
more casual and you get them and they
send them too and you
it just shocks you i mean you'll be a
damn crow and you'll spray these
these on these hawthorne scents and next
thing you know boy you out there
parakeet
and swear a keaton some of them even
make you just so fired up you know
they sent them to you they smell great
they're personalized it's premium
quality ingredients convenient easy to
buy online luxurious packaging
if you want to get a nice gift for
somebody hawthorne can help
you get the good scents but they also
sell deodorant shampoo
body wash face cleanser lotion etc
take the two minute quiz it's quick and
hawthorne tells you
the two colognes that are best for you
one for work one for play
totally risk-free with shipping and free
returns
check out hawthorne that's
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o that's right that's hawthorne
with an e
hawthorne.co and use my promo code
t-h-e-o to get 10 percent off your first
purchase
that's hawthorne dot co
and use my code t-h-e-o to get 10 off
your first purchase
hawthorne dot c-o
now is the time to celebrate football is
finally back do you watch football riley
now
i'm not a big fan okay great man well
the leader in one day fantasy sports
is draftkings that's right and there's
millions
of reasons you should be excited to kick
off the football season
draftkings is giving new users
a free shot at a one million dollar
top prize with a total of three million
dollars up for grabs
for this thursday's football contest
you hear me and i know a friend of mine
brenton biddlecombe won the million
dollars last year
he works at the comedy store and i don't
know if i supposed to tell people that
but getting in on thursday night's
single game showdown
is easy all you have to do is download
draftkings using promo code
t-h-e-o draft six players from the
season opener
stay under the salary cap and see how
your team stacks up against the
competition
so head to the app now and start making
it rain
new users who sign up today on
draftkings use code t-h-e-o
will receive a free shot at the one
million dollar top prize
with their first deposit nothing adds to
the sweat of watching
the game like having a shot at a million
dollar payday
so download the draftkings app now and
use code t-h-e-o
for a limited time new users get a free
shot at the one million dollar top
prize and three million dollars in total
prizes
don't miss out this extra special week
one bonus enter code
theo to get a free shot at the one
million dollar top prize with your first
deposit
that's code t-h-e-o only at draftkings
make it rain minimum five-dollar deposit
required
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
for details
oh now riley uh
do you ever donated blood i have
there you go man that's what i'm talking
about man and so you don't see a lot of
that
you know you youngsters don't know what
it's like man when i was growing up
blood you
you know now there's tons of blood
now you drive down the highway you see
you know you'll see blood on the damn
side of the road
but when i was young blood was a real
commodity
you know when i was growing up blood was
a there just wasn't as much blood man
you'd see you you'd have a friend that
have eight eight pints in them
you know and the requirement is nine
you'd have a friend you'd shake his hand
and it would feel
like almost like a beanbag chair because
he'd be a little
light on blood you know but now
everybody's got blood and there's just
i'm just saying you guys are spoiled man
your kids are real spoiled all right man
let's get into a little bit more what
happened dude and i want to say
uh i don't usually get angry but man
largeish
you gotta g up boo because that attitude
ain't gonna help you you know and then
pack in my bag like i'm
santa bruh dude i had to walk out of big
lots with two hands
two two two hands on the thing of my bag
walking out of there what are you are
you paying attention riley
i am indeed okay just seem like you're
not but that's all right
oh no i definitely am okay thank you
brother i do not believe you but i do
appreciate that
all right let's get into a call right
here now riley what we do on this show
is calls come in sometimes
you know and a lot of people are like
why is riley in here why is he in the
room
it's usually a solo episode and i don't
know the answer
you know i just i don't know the answer
you know i was nervous i'm in a new
place we're trying something new
uh by just being in a new place nick
isn't here
nick came here for a few days he seemed
a little stoned when he showed up
best judgment is that judgment riley i
don't think it is
thanks but nick will think it is though
i do know that
so let's get to your calls i want to say
thank you always the hotline is
985-664-9503
oh i saw leon bridges last night
you familiar with him yeah i saw him
i saw him playing music man and that's
really a beauty right there of nashville
that's the beauty of nashville man you
are somewhere and a piece of magic shows
up
and i mean if you have not seen leon
bridges
then i just don't even know what's wrong
with you
you might have eight pints of blood in
your body
the man is just me i mean he just
oh i felt like i went to church i felt
like i got married i felt like i got
buried i felt like
i learned to cook i felt like i had just
bought you know
five fresh scratchers all at once
i mean it's just like it's almost like
you opened up the your ears
and he's just over there just scooping
sugar into him
you know and he got that sound axe baby
he got that he got that freaking loud
hammer baby that guitar
and he's just serving bro he's just
agave you
up and you just leave out of there
filled with sweet ma
and he showed up and played the hits and
i'm talking about leon
bridges
so if anything gonna get you over
troubled water
you know what it is baby leon bridges
mine
as always the hotline is 985-664-9503
let's take a listen right here
hey phil this is uh alex
from uh kansas
and thank you for calling alex and i
appreciate it over there in kansas
and if you say kansas backwards this
spells uh
um saznack
let's hear more brother onward
wife and i have had like a lot of
animals we love
i my wife and i have had like a lot of
animals we live kind of on like a small
farm and i have an eight-year-old
daughter
and uh which sounds like a lot of
animals die
um because they'll have like unorthodox
stuff
like um chickens and like
lizards and fish and like all like
outdoor cats and
some like chinchillas and just weird
some weird stuff
and i always think like it'll be a great
experience for my daughter to
like rape yeah i'm gonna i'm just gonna
cut the call because it sounded you're
calling from a dang uh
one of those rock tumblers you know it
sounds like you're calling from the
inside of somebody's um
gastrointestine you know and they've
been eating a [ __ ] you know they had
a half a handful of rough cinnamon
you can't i don't know what you're
calling i mean you can't are you calling
from the middle of a
tectonic plate shift brother you got to
get your audio up daddy
and i'm sorry i know i'm sounding rude
but
you know largeish wasn't real nice to me
and it carries on so i'm sorry i'm kind
of i am kind of being rude but look i'm
people have called about this a lot you
know and you don't know this about me
riley i grew up i
used to raise hamsters when i was
growing up and i've been involved in a
lot of
small ground game my whole life okay
have you ever had any small animals
i have i had a dog when i was little
okay that's great man so what i'm
telling you is this brother is that
people call in and this man saying hey
how do we teach the kids when the
animals die how do we teach them a
lesson
how do we use it positively and this
fella's on a farm and yes when you're on
a farm you get different animals show up
you know you go out there one time
there's a little toucan out there
and he's putting up he's putting a
little uh you know a little uh
you know a little dip in his beak or
whatever
you know you go out in the morning
there'll be a herd of ants out there
you know pushing half of a damn jolly
rancher down the driveway
you know farms just animals know where
they are so
if they're in the nature they'll they'll
stop in
a group of sparrows will stop by and
attack a yard man
you know r.i.p big johnny over there too
in natchez mississippi and i used to
work with him
and he got ganged up on by a whole
swaggle at him sparrows but
a farm is based like the hampton inn of
mother nature's hampton inn
when animals see a farm they say oh yeah
let's stop here for the night
even if they're just passing through the
area but the way i've found to help
children learn about death you get a
little animal
and you name it the same name as uh the
grandparents
that's what they did in our family you
know
pop pop and clara
so then when they die you practice you
know
you get them that three-month roborovsky
hamster
you know and most of that market is
going to russia now but at the time
when i was growing up these were
beautiful animals they were well kept
you know they had full amount of blood
in them now you get a you know
you get one that's got 60 of blood it's
got a lot of
you know it's probably 40 saline
solution that's been dyed red you just
they're not the same a lot of that
market's gone to russia a lot of hamster
small ground game market um anyway i'm
rambling what i'm saying is you get the
animals you name them the grandparents
names
and when they pass away you practice
with the children
oh let's bury pop pop let's bury clara
let's bury uh zab let's bury laddie
let's bury jean let's bury uh
momma and then they get the hang of it
so then when you
when the actual grandparents die
it's you know now things can get a
little weird because
like hey let's flush grandpa down the
toilet and that's kind of
you know that's where you got to plan
ahead and what do they do in your
culture riley what have they done with
the animals
honestly it it depends uh fish would be
either down the toilet or in the ocean
um because you know i'm in california so
we have the whole pacific ocean next to
us um
for dogs i mean for my dog at least we
um i have a friend or my my friend's mom
she owned a bio urn uh company
so we had our dog turned into a tree
um so honestly it that's what they're
doing now you hear them
that's what the youngsters are doing
they're having their the dog turned into
a tree
unbelievable man and does it feel
positive to you what does that feel like
you think it does it does feel positive
until like you know there might be like
a tornado or something well i mean
obviously in california there's no
tornadoes but like if there's a tornado
here
like how there was and like if the plant
was here
well i would i would like run with the
plant
he would take the plant and leave with
it oh yeah yeah okay wow
but now you're on the hook now you got
this tree you got to care about
right now if it gets ants the tree gets
worms the tree gets you know
you know now at the middle of the night
somebody comes out there you're throwing
a frisbee against the tree
you know it's like it's not gonna
it just things are supposed to have a a
life path
right and now we're just continuing it
on
but that's california hey we'll put a
dead dog in a tree you know
that's if you know that's that next
they just keep you on the hook now
you're but you know now every month
for an extra 30 dollars they'll dump a
freaking you know
they'll open a can of cat food or
something put a set it on the branch or
something
so it just never ends uh
it just never ends man but
that's how you learn about death
and you mentioned they had a storm here
they had a tornado that came here
correct okay and people
and what how how how rough was it
it it did a lot of damage for sure it
did i think
i want to say a billion two billion
dollars worth of damage
dang really yeah it was a lot it tore
right through middle tennessee
it went from um from the middle of
nashville
all the way over to hermitage oh wow i
didn't know it was that bad
oh i know a soup plant i know it it
definitely took down today's soup
plantation over there in hendersonville
yeah and that broke a lot of hearts but
one thing that gets me is mother nature
is going to do what she's going to do
and it's how we react to it
you know and everybody also wants to
play a victim a lot of times with mother
nature
oh mother no oh it's so
hot well you live in the s you live on
earth
you know there's sun in the air you
can't be shocked
that it there's warmth that there's warm
coming out of it
you know you can't be shocked if you if
you live on a glacier
that your feet get cold you got
you got you know and everybody wants to
be oh
you know the tornado and you know we
were about 60 miles from it and the
power went out
we lost power some lady kept telling me
that ain't look get a candle boo
you didn't look losing pow losing power
is not your arms don't work
that's losing power you know when you
can't hug anybody you just gotta rub
your neck against them to let them know
you care
that's losing power
okay or your legs don't work
and you gotta elbow crawl to the door to
get a damn amazon box you know
that's losing power you know electricity
you light a candle
and you can change all that up but that
is how you
you name the pets after the grandparents
that's how it works
or you know what name the pets largeish
bro
because she's got something coming i'll
tell you that
um let's go to uh
let's go to another call right here here
we go
hey theo it's your boy future army
helicopter pilot mikey
what's up mikey and thank you for
calling and good luck out there in that
military bro
it's my first year away from home and
i'm spending all this [ __ ] dorm
money on
ugh and why did he have to curse you
think right there
riley now who knows it's just how how he
talks
yeah okay
you're right you're right onward on a
virtual education for my rotc
okay you take an rotc virtually okay
onward goddess doing sweat activities on
the zoom call son
anyways they got these college girl
hitters in the zoom call and i want some
advice on catching their attention
with these opposite sex hitters black to
the online calls
sometimes i make them laugh by mirroring
what they do on the call
and that's really all i've done so far
um any advice on
catching the attention of these these
fine ladies
um gang gang don't do coke onward
gang brother do you do cocaine rally i
don't
all right so what this man is asking
about is being on zoom and
flirting with women and i guess there's
there's something to be said for having
some zoom game
you know i think one thing you can do i
love the idea of mirroring what the lady
is doing
that's like a cute way of flirting kinda
you know she drinks out of something you
drink out of something
you know she puts on a you know what do
a lipstick you do a lipstick
you know she you know pets an animal or
something you pet an animal
i really like that i also think you need
to you
want to have stuff in the atmosphere
that shows a woman how you feel you want
to set something nice out there
get your little plant get your little
bonsai out there
little cactus man you know set a nice
some shoes or something in the back
something nice
you know you want to have you you just
want to have a
you want to have nice things you know if
you're eating something make sure it's
something classy
you know get a plant and even you could
do gardening while you're on the call
do a start doing a little garden
you know and do something sexual throw a
little you know plant a couple viagra
plant a couple blue chews throw out the
vibe say hey
you know i'm ready to grow a little root
for you mommy
you know you gotta you gotta you know
you gotta plan ahead a little bit
you know leave things out that are good
leave things out that she'll see on the
zoom
things that you know some fresh bread a
little freaking
some remotes you know different remote
controllers let her know you got a
little bit of money
you know do that kind of thing it's
gentleman it up
hang a tuxedo in the distance you know
put on some james bond or something in
the background
you know get a picture of download a
picture of rich parents google rich
parents
on the internet print it out hang it up
plan ahead so that's easy brother
and you're welcome for that all right i
do want to let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by
ray khan and uh
and look everybody listens to thing you
listen a different thing
you might hear something what was that
somebody dropped a
you know um maybe somebody dropped a
seashell or dropped a p a crowbar
well what i'm telling you is the best
way to listen is by using a pair of
premium wireless earbuds
especially if you can get premium ones
at less than half the price of the other
guys
that's why i recommend wireless earbuds
from
raycon look i'll listen to some raycon
i'll put on something
you know i'll put on some dang leon
bridges
and just heal myself raycon's newest
model the everyday
e25 earbuds the e25s
are their best ones yet don't you want
to hear some
don't you want to hear something while
you can
then get the dang earbuds
raycon's e25 have six hours of play time
not like these other ones they short out
in a half hour
your mom calls you one time and you're
done
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass
a more compact design and a noise
isolating fit
raycon earbuds are stylish and discreet
no dangling wires
no stems yeah some of them they got that
little dangler you know
looks like a little ear pond the company
was co-founded by ray j
and celebrities like brandy j.r smith
mike tyson
all use e25 ray connie or buds
for a limited time get fifteen percent
off your order at buy
buy raycon
dot com slash t-h-e-o that's
b-u-y-r-a-y-c-o-n
dot c-o-m slash t-h-e-o for a special 15
discount on raycon wireless earbuds
check them out i mean get the dang
earbuds
it's it's the deal is running by
raycon dot com slash theo the best price
premium this episode is brought to you
by
better help you know better help is uh
it's just a
i mean it's help man and it's better
we all need help you know i've been in i
remember getting trapped in a hole when
i was young
you know and finally a man came along
and helped me out
and he tickled me for about an hour
afterwards and made me sick actually
but everybody needs help better help
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed
professional therapist
look people don't have anybody to talk
to people are pulling up behind a
winn-dixie
you know and pleasuring themselves in
their own automobiles and crying
there's a broad range of expertise and
better helps counselor network
which may not be locally available in
many areas
some areas it's you know they don't have
a therapist around
or maybe it's your the therapist is your
wife or your husband's friend
or somebody your brother used to date i
ain't going to talk to sandra
i ain't going to talk to you know
smallisha
so it changes man this this this way you
can do it discreetly
you can log on to your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
betterhelp has a way where you can
communicate with your counselor over
text
over phone even over facetime
you know i was heading to a poker game
one time and almost lost my mind
i pulled over to the side of the road
and next thing you know i'm getting help
and that was through better help start
living a happier life today visit
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's
h b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e l p and join the over
500 000 people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
special offer for this past weekend
listeners get 10 off your first
month at com betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o
we also have a labor day sale going on
at theovonstore.com
i believe it's 25 off and that runs
through
september 12th so get on there and get
some good items
you know and get something for yourself
or get something for someone else you
can do it
i know you can what else is going on oh
in the news i saw this
um that uh
they had a gender reveal party and they
lit up the dang
forest in california
a couple people trying to beat open up
you know
a f uh you know somebody trying to beat
open a flaming armoire
with a golf club just so they can let
you know who their son what the
gender of their son is and california
said we ain't having any of it
and now there's a forest fire over seven
thousand acres
of male and female forest
have been burnt to the ground
that's that look man they don't you
gotta
california's not they don't nobody has a
gender there's no more gender there
they ain't doing gender
they ain't doing gender you try to
reveal anything's gender
fire that's the new rule there
oh you want to see this you want to see
it you know see if the baby gots a titty
or something they shooting open a damn
water balloon with a cannon do the baby
gots a titty or wiener or whatever
bam fire
the gender reveals they can't handle it
you know when i was young riley mal when
i was young you would look
you know you got to be five or six years
old you'd sneak off and look in your
pants and see what you were
i remember not i didn't know what i was
you know i remember one time
i'm over at my friend's house he's a
little bit kind of he was kind of fat a
little kind of chubby guy
and he was taking a break he was always
doing that you know we'd play any game
we'd be
10 seconds into the game and he would
turn red enough to take a break
so i snuck off behind his house over
about a kind of about a firewood
looked in my pants and i was a man
there wasn't no party there wasn't no
cake after there wasn't no petty
fours you know no balloons no bs
but there wasn't any fire you know you
youngsters you want everybody you know
you know you got a wiener you want
everybody to have a damn
you know slice of homemade pie or
something
so just different man
it's just different what else have i
been seeing a lot of um
dude you know what i was thinking a lot
of these blm rallies it's all
white people that's how lame they've
gotten
black people aren't even showing up to
them anymore
could you imagine if a black guy showed
up to a blm rally he would be like this
has gotten bad
this has gotten i i i just can't even
imagine
i'll say this um there's people fighting
in the parks and stuff and you keep
seeing it
this is what is it's our renaissance
fair
you know it the world has gotten a
little more violent
they got the ufc now you can watch
people
beat each other into unconsciousness
in three minute increments on the
weekend
brought to you by toyo tires
they're selling you tires while somebody
is losing
their ability to recognize their family
members
that's that's why a lot of protesting i
think you get these antifa you get these
proud boys you know you get these wild
cats out there
that's the new renaissance fair get a
turkey leg
go to the park
and watch them larp it out
that's all it is
that's all it is let's take a couple
more calls that came in
um here we go what's up theo it's your
boy jim from jacksonville
what's up jim and jim can be short for a
lot of different names bro
jimothy um
[Music]
let's hear more i was wondering if you
had any thoughts on this walk
seems like whops are hiding streets
right now
i wonder if you had any thoughts or
comments on it that [ __ ]
worship and praise my brother praise the
lord amen baby ptl brother i feel you
and a lot of people are talking you know
they have a lot of uh
risque music out there you know and they
got the new song
[ __ ] and it sounds for it stands for wet
private parts basically female
crotch for me i don't i don't listen to
it
i just don't you know i just don't
i think it's more of a girl's song
you know i just don't listen to it man
i don't listen when i was young wap was
also a racial slur i think even
you know and so i'm not if i go around
yelling [ __ ]
you know i just don't want to get
involved in any you know i don't want my
grandfather to get
excited and run and grab a weapon you
know that kind of [ __ ]
so i don't listen to it brother jim from
jacksonville i appreciate you calling i
don't
you know i just don't need to be
thinking about it
because i have enough visions in my head
of female
body crotch titty shoulder area
you know neck back leg nice leg
you know and i'm trying to keep i just
and it's okay to have them i just don't
want to be
you know touching myself so that's why
i'm trying not to
i don't need to be driving around as an
adult man
listening to um
[Music]
someone yelling about their crotch being
wet
i don't i don't
need that okay great man onward let's
take one more call here that we got uh
that we got here let's let's hear it
yo what's up theo this is nick from uh
just outside of baltimore and maryland
the safe side
but uh this past weekend my girlfriend
and i we took a trip
to lancaster or lancaster pennsylvania
you know out there in amish country and
we saw
this girl yeah yeah lancaster
on like this scooter slash bike that
didn't have wheels
and she was moving faster than a horse
literally faster than a horse i thought
man what what are we missing out on what
if the amish
were in the olympics think about that
i was like man i know you're always
thinking about the next
uh movie that you and your podcast
buddies could do
you talked about wrestling or something
like that but i want you guys to do the
amish
olympics anyhow man the amish olympics
huh and this riley this is a fella
calling this guy's
obviously under the influence of drugs
marijuana
you know this guy's driving through
pennsylvania
he's his girlfriend and they are
watching a child and a horse
they're watching a child on a scooter
pass a horse
you know the amish were the original
aliens you know before they went to
aliens oh
space there's people in space you know
being crazy
doing this kind of stuff and
you know lasers all of that
they had the amish that was the original
alien
like hey let's go watch a guy hang
laundry
are like no let's go watch a guy make
his own milk or milk his wife
like no you're kid
and then you go and you'd see it or you
just
you know you'd be in the woods to be a
couple of men
and that's a police i guess i don't know
if you see the studio here it's i mean
we have a limited it is
learn as we go it's been a learning
experience man it's been a little bit of
a trying time
but what i'm telling this guy amish
olympics let's do it
i'm ready to see every i'm ready to see
everybody in it
and i want to know where the black amish
are
wear the black amish you want to get out
there you want to do something different
find these people
find these people and report them
all right man let's take one more call
this has been a wild episode it's been
you know we're do we're getting through
this that's what this is called i think
getting through this i want to say
um i want to thank everybody for their
patience
as we you know this episode we got it
out a little bit late this week
but we you know we had to make sure that
we're figuring things out
there's not a you know we're missing you
get over to different areas of the
country they don't have the same people
you don't have the same you know you
can't just you know kidnap somebody and
next thing you know they know how to
help produce a
a podcast or edit video
you know it's just not the same
it's not the same types of people
so it takes them so you got to look
through the woods a little
you got to find your black amish you
know
you got to find that rare person that
alien that
unique that largeish
um and let's take one more call that
came he
came in here here we go yo
theo this is jesse man you just gave me
a call this afternoon
and uh you know um
what's up jesse yeah i remember man this
is last week but i do remember bro
uh i hope you're doing well man and yeah
thanks for uh for chatting with me
onward
i've been thinking about it well i just
got out of work and i've been thinking
about it and like
you know i feel bad cause like you know
i was i felt like i was just you know
maybe i'm just overthinking but
i feel like i was discrediting your
feelings because i was like
in the you know star struck kind of
moment
of of you know you giving me a call or
whatever and like you know you were
expressing to me some
some things you were going through and
like you know looking back on it i was
kind of like dismissive of it i think
and you know
maybe i'm just overthinking that's what
i do but um
i just wanted to express that to you and
uh
how grateful i am that you actually did
reach out man because it did help me
today i was going through a lot today
and i've been going through a lot lately
and i you know i try to put on a mask of
everything's great and golden but you
know there's just nice life's going on
and stuff you know so
we can get through anything together you
know what i mean we do together with you
i can't do alone you know
so you know my my celebrations coming up
here september 26 on the zoom platform
and um i'm pretty excited for that dude
thanks again for calling man keep up the
good work and you know
keep that gratitude man i'm grateful for
you every day dude love you gang
thanks man that's a nice message man
that's a really nice message uh
yeah i i don't i don't think that you
were rude man you know i i i
and i didn't mean to surprise you just
with the call but
um but i i'm glad that we got to chat
a little and yeah i overthink everything
man
i overthink everything like dang
like i'll like dude i will go i'll be
like damn man
was that too weird in that meeting like
did i stay sometimes i'll be talking
i'll be list
in a conversation i'll be like am i
looking at this person for too long
like do i blink right now do i what do i
do
touch my face oh i wish i had some gum
and some i'll keep a little you know a
baby snicker or a jolly rancher
in my pocket so i can open it up you
know if i start to about eight seconds
into just staring somebody in the eyes
it's like okay blink have a jr
you know break up the momentum
but we do it together man we do
everything together you know and i
appreciate your call back and just
man you're golden in my book and just
the fact
that you thought to give me a call and
just say hey man that means a lot you
know and just
and that you cared how i was thinking or
that you know it's
you know we're here on earth and this is
the gift is each other
you know the gift is each other
and it's been a there's been a rough
time for a lot of people you know a lot
of
you know we get addicted to the news and
addicted to the
watching the the drama and
[Music]
and i was thinking the past week i've
been thinking man uh people over
politics i've been thinking
you know i care about people i don't
care i don't care i don't care about
politics
i don't it does i it just it's too much
of an argumentative space
there's no it's all it all feels like a
dirty show
you know i i so what can we affect what
can we be a part of that feels good is i
feel like is each other
you know i'm tired i don't need all the
extracurriculars
you know i'm just going to show up and
just feed the ducks man
you know if large east wants to be off
you know if she wants to be a large east
that's fine
i'll be a small i'm just going to try
and be a small geesh man
you know i'm going to check in with
people that i love and people that i
that i know care about me i'm just going
to try to keep it going
but for me man i just i don't want to be
in though
i don't want to be in that hurricane man
it just i i just noticed more
i don't know man i'm not trying to
preach at you i just
you know when i look back on the past
few months
and i just feel like oh the just all the
stuff and the opini
the the stuff online and the opinions i
get and then i get angry at this person
and
then it's like man i'm angry i'm getting
upset with people and opinions and stuff
of people that i care about
you know what's real here
um
so i don't know i don't know what i'm
talking about
but i'm just glad i'm not a dang
pedophile i'm glad i'm not
you know there's things to be grateful
for
and we got each other and we're trying
something new
and i'm glad i don't have to try it
alone man i do two days ago i'm sitting
in here and i'm like man i'm never gonna
get this studio put together
i'm not gonna be able to figure it out
you know three days ago i was just
bombed man
and now i'm sitting here you know i'm
sitting here
we got a place they got fresh paint
you know we got another human here
you know sitting here working with you
know people from different cultures
different worlds
and it's okay you know we just keep
going man we keep going onward
i think that's it
riley mao anything else you need to say
man no
i think this was a uh this was great i
loved being here
great to be here i like your attitude
brother
i like your attitude man um
all right let's roll out on some shine
the same we wrote the same way we rolled
in man
people say i'm tired hearing it that's
sometimes i'm tired of hearing it
but it's keeping me going you know i am
excited about getting uh
i'm excited about getting
[Music]
um some musicians different musicians
and introducing their music through the
podcast
you know different nashville musicians
and just trying to focus on that again
getting some new music and
giving you know young artists a platform
and
you know i'm excited about that um
you know and it's sometimes we can't
even be in the results of things
you know we had uh you know with the
last episode solo episode we try
to reach out to some of the different
single mothers and
and say hey to them and we're gonna you
know it's taking a little bit but we're
gonna send them some cards and do
you know send a little gift to help out
with just some of them being a part of
doing fun stuff with their kids and
you know and uh and we got just some
feet just kickback from it about you
know one of the moms have an only fans
account
you know and it just
you know you just do what you can
you know and it's even when you try to
do something good
sometimes it don't or whatever it just
you know it it's not always going to be
perceived that way
oh well you know
it just you just try you just try and
you go again
and you do something you just do what
you can
you know
you just do what you can
um you know why i'm not i don't know why
i'm really sharing that with you guys
but
it just i don't know it just you do what
you can
you you there's no i don't even know if
you all if you ever win you just do what
you can
everybody's just trying to survive i
really believe that everybody's just
trying to survive and
you know and we do what we can man but
i'm glad to be here today with you
and um and i appreciate you being
supportive of this podcast as we
every as we expand and get this central
east location we'll still be going back
to la
we're trying things out we're trying
something new
and and i'm trying to stay hopeful man
and i'm not doing it alone thank you
raleigh mao for being in here today
and um being a true japanese hawaiian is
that your
culture correct them jay has man
beautiful people
and uh and thank you producer nick davis
who flew over here
with his girlfriend and they came and
helped out and
you know it takes a village huh right
right exactly you know we can't do
things alone can we
not at all you always need someone to
help yeah
it's true man sometimes i want to do
things just alone i get i just get stuck
that way you know
right same do you really
but then whenever i do decide okay i'm
gonna do it with somebody else i feel
end up feeling better
right it's a lot easier with someone
else whether you just need them
whether you need
yeah it man
i'm glad you said that all right you
guys be good to yourselves man
uh you deserve it and we'll see you guys
next time okay
[Music]
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
blown
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be cornerstone
[Music]
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
in my bones thought it's gonna
take a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself go
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway
[Music]
of where i'm going
i'll sit and tell you about stories
[Music]
if you call my name
my stories
[Music]
just for you
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
me
you